Good morning, Hank.
It's Tuesday, and in a stunning turn of events
I find myself... in an airport.
Wardrobe change!
Hank, today's video comes to you in four very
special parts.
Part one: your tour!
Hank, your tour seems to be going well.
I wish I was there, but you know what?
I-I can't sing or play an instrument, so I
would be kind of irrelevant.
Reviews of your tour so far include that it
was "so fun," that people had "the best time
ever," and that you are a "surprisingly competent
musician."
Which analysis I have to say I agree with,
Hank.
I mean back in 2007 when you released your
love song for Helen Hunt, I had no idea that
you could even play the guitar- let alone
write and sing.
And watching that video my main feeling wasn't
like "oh this is a great song" or anything,
although it was, it was "when did Hank get
a guitar?"
So, yeah, Nerdfighters, if you're in any of
these cities, go to Hank's tour.
Part two: Batman's Just a Rich Guy With an
Affinity for Bats.
So Hank, when I showed our two competing shirt
designs to Sarah, she laughed for like eight
minutes and then finally said "Why would anyone
buy a shirt that says 'Batman's just a rich
guy with an affinity for bats'?"
So, yeah.
If I can't even convert my wife, I'm concerned
about my ability to win this contest.
But both these shirts are available for preorder
until April, 25th and then they will never
be available again....
I mean unless they are for some reason.
I don't know.
The future is unpredictable.
Part three: Why We're in the Airport.
So, Hank, Sarah and I are on our way to attend
gala (gay-la) or possibly a gala (gah-la).
Hold on....
According to the dictionary, both are acceptable.
It's like GIF and JIFF.
So, we're going to a gala (gay-la) gala (gah-la)-
the word so fancy, they named it twice.
This gala (gay-la) gala (gah-la) is to celebrate
the Time 100, Time magazine's list of the
100 most important people in the world.
Hank, you might remember that ridiculously
last year, I-I was on that list.
This year I have apparently declined in importance,
so didn't make the list, but I did snag an
invite to the party!
I can't tell you how excited I am to have
declined in significance, Hank.
Long may it continue.
This could save me the embarrassment of having
to explain to other members of the Time 100
exactly why I was on the list- which happened
a lot at last year's gala (gay-la) gala (gah-la).
Rand Paul, or whatever, would be like "Who
are you exactly?" and I would be like "Oh,
I'm the guy who popularized the phrase French
the Llama" and he would be like "Yeah, that's
not a thing."
This year, I don't have to do any of that
stuff.
When people ask who I am, I'll just be like
"I'm Rand Paul's date."
Part four: Strange Marriages
Hank, your airport video about strange marriages
reminded me of a strange marriage I just heard
about... or at least a strange engagement.
So, many years ago, Hank, in 2008 the first
Nerdfighter gathering in Europe that I attended
happened in Amsterdam.
There were like 30 or 40 Nerdfighters there
and it was just kinda like a party!
And after it had been going on for about an
hour a Dutch Nerdfighter I knew from her video
series, "Best Wishes from The Netherlands",
came up to me and she was like: "Can you introduce
us to the Belgian boys they have cute accents?"
And now 7 years later one of those Dutch girls-
now woman- is marrying one of those Belgian
boys-now man!
So congratulations to them...
I love it when Nerdfighter-like turns into
Nerdfighter-love.
So Hank the weirdest part is that at any one
of your concerts in the next couple of weeks
like Nerdfighters could meet and fall in love
and 7 years later get engaged!
Okay they just called my name for final boarding
call, I, uhh, oh boy.
I've got like, my tux shoes and my backpack
and everything is totally disorganized.
I hope I make it to the plane, I hope I make
it to the plane.....
MADE IT.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.